Steven Seagal was one of the biggest
action stars of the 90s so where's he
been lately from his weird Bromance with
a foreign dictator through his brief
foray as a spy novelist here's what the
above the Lost star has been up to
starting in the late 80s Steven Seagal
took a side job as a police consultant
in Jefferson Parish Louisiana Sheriff
Harry Lee a big Seagal fan asked the
action star to train his force in
martial arts and Marksmanship Seagal
loved the job and did it for so long
that Lee eventually enlisted him as a
reserve Deputy in 2009 Segal's side gig
became the basis for a reality show on a
e called Steven Seagal Lawman it was
similar to Cops and that a film crew
tagged along while police officers
investigated local crimes as they
happened the big difference obviously
was that the star of Under Siege was
there no matter how great our deputies
are there's always going to be areas
that are problematic and we're trying to
get those Airways sadly Seagal
reportedly resigned from the force in
2010 after he became the subject of an
internal affairs investigation according
to the Phoenix New Times the
investigation sought to uncover the
truth about allegations of sex
trafficking and sexual assault those
allegations were corroborated by two
other female ex-employees who alleged
similar treatment by the actor however
their suit against Segal was dropped
later in the year you may be thinking
that Steven Seagal is very well suited
for a role in a scripted cop series
after all TV shows about the police are
always pretty popular and Segal spent
years beating up bad guys in movies well
you'd be right because it actually
happened in 2011 Seagal took his crime
fighting butt kicking act to TV with the
action series True Justice in addition
to creating True Justice Seagal played
Elijah Kane on the series the head of an
elite undercover Seattle task force the
show first aired in Spain on a cable
channel called Nitro before showing up
on the American Movie Network reels True
Justice ran for two seasons in October
2017 Inside Edition correspondent Lisa
Guerrero told The Hollywood Reporter
about her 1996 audition for Seagal's
Fire Down Below according to Guerrero
Segal summoned her to his home for a
private rehearsal after the audition
Guerrero declined in the lead role she
said she was promised went to another
actor you're an actress in Hollywood you
have been Harvey weinsteined in my case
I was Harvey weinsteined by Steven
Seagal television personality Jenny
McCarthy also spoke out thanks Segal
demanded she take off her dress during
an audition for Under Siege 2. according
to Entertainment Weekly Segal denied
McCarthy's allegations in January 2018
Rachel Grant a former Bond girl who
appeared in the 007 movie Die Another
Day went public with their own story
about Seagal's alleged abuse Grant told
the BBC that during her audition for
Seagal's 2003 film out for a kill he
pushed John to a bed and pulled down his
pants again Segal denied any wrongdoing
additionally in January 2018 two women
filed police reports in Los Angeles that
alleged Segal had sexually assaulted
them one of the women was Regina Simons
who appeared as an extra in Seagal's
1994 action film on deadly ground in her
report Simons offered a detailed account
of Segal sexually assaulting her when
she was 18. one reached for comment the
LAPD cited confidentiality laws however
the department did reveal that they were
investigating yet another claim against
Segal according to the rap after the
multiple allegations surfaced it quickly
became apparent that Seagal would have
to do more than just have his publicist
deny the allegations so the actor went
on the offensive while appearing on Alex
Jones Infowars Seagal told the host that
he was the victim of a vast well-funded
conspiracy the actor also added that 40
percent of the sexual assault
allegations coming out of the hashtag
metoo movement were made up Segal also
vowed revenge on the people he said were
lying Steven Seagal is reportedly good
friends with fellow martial arts movie
star Jackie Chan so while Rush Hour 3
was entering production in 2007 Chan was
rumored to have suggested that Seagal
play the film's villain however he
didn't end up in the role and the script
was ultimately Rewritten to accommodate
Japanese actor hiroyuki Sonata Segal
missed another opportunity for a huge
comeback when he passed on a role in
Sylvester Stallone's 2010 Hit The
Expendables the film showed that there
was still a big audience for 80s style
action movies as well as 80s style
action heroes the cast of The
Expendables series included Stallone
himself Chuck Norris and Jean-Claude Van
Damme missing from that list however was
Steven Seagal Segal ultimately declined
Stallone's offer because he hated one of
the movie's producers Avi Lerner the
Under Siege star and learner had
previously worked on several direct
video features together Steven Seagal
lives a very full life outside of making
movies he also spends a lot of time
traveling around the world visiting his
friends who live abroad as it happens
two of his best friends are Buddhist
spiritual leader the Dalai Lama and
Russian President Vladimir Putin in
addition to his International Friends
Segal gained citizenship in Serbia in
January 2016. when he offered to set up
a martial arts studio there Seagal's
Bromance with Putin has earned the star
some enemies when he told the Russian
state-run newspaper rasikaya gaizetta
that he considers Putin one of the great
living world leaders and that he thinks
of the Russian leader like a brother he
is one of the greatest world leaders and
one of the greatest presidents in the
world furthermore after Putin personally
granted Segal a Russian passport in 2016
thus formally making him a citizen of
the country the actor was banned from
entering Ukraine writing in a letter
that was published on the news site
apostrophe Ukrainian officials said
Steven Seagal has committed socially
dangerous actions that contradict the
interests of maintaining Ukraine's
security
two Steven Seagal films The Foreigner
and contract to kill earned the not so
prestigious score of zero percent on
Rotten Tomatoes that means that every
critic who saw both films didn't like
them regarding the Foreigner Scott
Weinberg a v-film critics said in his
review this movie is so bad that it
makes Seagal's other films look like the
combined efforts of Frank Capra and
Billy Wilder as for contract to kill a
Critic for the AV club wrote Steven
Seagal gives the kind of performance
traditionally associated with stars who
died during filming and yet Segal is in
almost every scene who is the target so
what do the critics think about the rest
of Segal's recent direct to video
filmography well those movies haven't
even been seen by enough people to be
rated yet in fact as of May 2023 a
whopping 53 of his movies since 2001 are
listed as no score yet on Rotten
Tomatoes despite the action star's
incredibly long filmography you can
count on one hand the number of
certified fresh movies he has
if you believe there's a secret
globalist agenda that threatens to
destroy the United States what's the
best way of getting your message out
well since this is exactly what Steven
Seagal believes his answer was to write
an action spy novel titled the way of
the Shadow wolves the Deep state in the
hijacking of America co-credited to
Segal and writer Tom Morrissey the novel
is billed as a book of fiction based on
reality the plot follows an Arizona
tribal officer who untangles a
high-reaching conspiracy among drug
smugglers the mainstream media and the
United States government as with many of
Seagal's films the reviews weren't
exactly kind in December 2017 the AV
club highlighted a series of Amazon
write-ups in social media posts that
gleefully mocked the book in its authors
furthermore AV club critic Nathan Rabin
hate read the entire book in order to
offer an in-depth rundown of the story
on the other hand the right-wing classic
rocker Ted Nugent posted on Facebook
that he loves Seagal's book in September
2017 Seagal appeared on Good Morning
Britain to weigh in on the national
anthem at the time a large number of
professional athletes were protesting
racial Injustice and inequality in
America by opting not to stand during
the anthem we have a lot of people that
aren't treated equally you aren't given
equal opportunities it's a complicated
issue that's inspired no shortage of
debate but from Seagal's point of view
it's all very simple while insisting
that he believed in free speech Segal
made it clear that he was deeply
offended by the idea that anyone would
refuse to stand during the anthem he
told host Piers Morgan I don't agree
they should hold the United States of
America and the world hostage by picking
a venue where people are tuning in to
watch a football game and imposing their
political views I think it's outrageous
I think it's a joke it's disgusting
according to multiple actors Steven
Seagal is an incredibly difficult person
to work with John Leguizamo who
co-starred with Seagal in 1996 executive
decision discovered this the hard way
while filming the action thriller Segal
got angry with this co-star and
allegedly shoved Leguizamo against the
wall Seagal also made life hard for the
Saturday Night Live cast while hosting
the show in 1991 he was very critical of
the cast in writing staff according to
live from New York the complete
uncensored history of Saturday Night
Live As Told by its Stars writers and
guests Tim Meadows is even quoted as
saying in the book Steven Seagal didn't
realize that you can't tell somebody
they're stupid on Wednesday and expect
them to continue writing for you on
Saturday David Spade meanwhile said that
in his six years on Saturday Night Live
Segal was the absolute worst host which
probably had a lot to do with his taste
in comedy for instance former cast
member Julia Sweeney noted in live from
New York that Seagal had an idea for a
sketch in which he played a therapist
who attempts to sleep with a rape
Survivor as it turned out Segal was so
impossible to work with that he was
banned from ever hosting Saturday Night
Live Again Stephen toboloski also
learned firsthand about Seagal's
difficulty on set in the Glimmer Man
tobovsky played a serial killer so
naturally Segal was supposed to blow the
bad guy away but then as toblovsky told
the AV club Segal decided it was bad for
his karma to keep killing people on
screen so he wanted to balowsky's
character to survive
don't make me do this thinking on his
feet topolovsky quickly explained that
his character was trapped in his own
private hell so by killing the villain
Segal would be allowing the bad guy to
reincarnate as a more peaceful being
Segal agreed and the scene went on as
scripted in addition to acting Steven
Seagal has done quite a bit of fight
choreography according to IMDb most of
the films he's choreographed are his own
in the early 80s however Segal worked on
the James Bond film Never Say Never
Again apparently he was brought in to
teach Sean Connery about martial arts
Connery however was already well versed
in karate while preparing for 1967's You
Only Live Twice he was even awarded an
honorary third degree black belt but for
his seventh outing as Bond Connery
needed to learn a little Aikido so Segal
was hired to teach him how to throw
opponents and manipulate joints at first
the lessons seemed to be going well in
fact they were going too well as Connery
admitted to Jay Leno on The Tonight Show
in 1996. and then I got a little cocky
because I thought I knew what I was
doing but then things took a turn for
the worse from there an irritated Segal
allegedly grabbed Conor's arm and broke
the actor's wrist Marley was undoubtedly
in pain Connery kept on training in fact
he didn't realize that Seagal had
actually snapped his wrist until the
late 90s of course Segal can take a bit
of pain as well while working on his
breakout film 1988's Above the Law actor
Henry Silva broke Segal's nose with an
overzealous punch knowing The Show Must
Go On Seagal stayed up late that night
icing his battered nose so he could keep
on shooting the next day Steven Seagal
has battled all sorts of bad guys on the
Silver Screen from terrorists to the
Yakuza but he's also faced some scary
villains in real life namely the mafia
in the 90s Seagal teamed up with
producer Julius arnesso together the duo
made a string of hits however their
relationship soured in 2000 and the two
eventually had a falling out but things
took a dark turn when the gambino crime
family got involved one day Seagal was
ordered into a car and escorted to a
Brooklyn restaurant it was there that he
met an alleged Gambino Captain named
Anthony Sonny chicone according to CBS
News chiconi ordered Segal to start
working with nasso again he also
demanded that Segal Fork over 100
hundred and fifty thousand dollars for
every film he made evidently Segal was
so shaken he gave the gangster seven
hundred thousand dollars the martial
artist had every reason to be afraid
because as CBS News reported as Segal
left the meeting someone supposedly told
him if you would have said the wrong
thing they would have killed you the
Scandal came to light in 2003 when the
government indicted alleged crime boss
Peter Gotti and 16 others for a whole
host of crimes in addition to Segal's
testimony the government had recordings
of several individuals including chicone
and nasso in the recordings the two men
discussed how they would intimidate
Segal they even laughed about how they
had scared the movie star NASA defended
himself by saying segald had backed out
of several movie deals and owed him five
hundred thousand dollars regardless the
producer was sentenced to one year in
federal prison but once a crooked mob
guy always a crooked mob guy NASA wanted
his cash and sued Segal for 60 million
dollars after the producer got out of
jail he settled with Segal for an
undisclosed amount of money while never
a critical darling Steven Seagal used to
pull in some impressive box office
numbers but throughout the 2010s the
majority of Seagal's films went straight
to DVD or streaming furthermore Seagal
isn't making as many movies as he used
to in fact as of April 2023 Seagal's
last film Beyond the law was released in
2019. so what happened to Steven
Seagal's career well he blames his
decline on the FBI in 2002 Los Angeles
Times Reporter Anita Bush was
investigating Seagal about Julius nasso
and the producers association with the
mafia but one morning she found a dead
fish a rose and a sign that red stop on
our windshield there was also a brand
new bullet hole in her car afraid Bush
informed the FBI as a result the feds
began investigating Segal at first the
FBI thought the actor had hired a
detective named Anthony pelicano to
intimidate Bush pelicano was a private
eye who would later be convicted of
illegally spying on celebrities the FBI
also suspected Segal of hiring a thug to
scare Vanity Fair writer Ned Zeman with
a gun I know you don't I but after
digging deeper the FBI concluded there
was no evidence against the Gaul instead
they focused on pelicano and then Seagal
just fell by the wayside the FBI never
charged him but they didn't exonerate
him either according to the Los Angeles
Times Story the actor believes all the
notoriety from the pelicano case majorly
harmed his career and he may have a
point as one Hollywood publicist told
the Los Angeles Times Steven Seagal was
no Harrison Ford when this Scandal
happened but these accusations certainly
hastened his decline so it only makes
sense that Segal wants an apology from
the FBI for possibly destroying his
career as for pelicano he was convicted
on wiretapping charges in 2008 and sent
to prison having served his time
pelicano was released in March of 2019.
Steven Seagal's hands are just for
breaking people's bodies they're also
for making sweet sweet music yes the
star of hard to kill is also a longtime
musician who loves the blues whether the
blues loves him back is another question
entirely segol has been playing guitar
since age 12. and heads the Steven
Seagal blues band it wasn't until 2005
however that Segal released his first
album songs from The Crystal Cave the
album features straightforward Blues
though the songs aren't nearly as grimy
and Soulful as something you might hear
from BB King or Buddy Guy in fact
Sputnik Music called the album The Plan
9 from Outer Space of Records there are
various reasons for the album's harsh
criticism such as Seagal's mumbling
half-asleep singing style the actor is
less than impressive guitar playing also
didn't wow the critics additionally the
album featured some downright bizarre
lyrics such as this gem you're like a
ghost the more you eat the more you're
hungry a hungrier ghost he's got Russian
citizenship a willingness to offer as
many opinions on a wide variety of
subjects and a measure of celebrity so
it was probably only a matter of time
before the Russian government offered
Steven Seagal a job that time came in
August 2018 when Seagal was made a
special Envoy for humanitarian ties with
the United States that's a fancy
sounding gig but as the Russian foreign
Ministry noted when announcing Seagal's
appointment it's an unpaid position it's
also a position that's a little
difficult to understand at least in
terms of Seagal actually being able to
get anything done as the ministry's
description of the Roll notes the
envoy's job is to facilitate relations
between Russia and United States in the
humanitarian field including cooperation
and culture arts public and youth
exchanges
one of 2022's most original and
critically adored films was the menu a
black comedy served with a zest of
social commentary and a dash of horror
among other big names who appeared in
the film such as Rafe finds Anya Taylor
joy and Nicholas Holt the movie featured
John Leguizamo as a movie star named
George Diaz in the film The Diaz
character is no longer relevant as a
movie star instead Fading Into Obscurity
as he becomes an ever-increasing Target
of ridicule for inspiration and playing
this washed up has been Leguizamo chose
his former co-star Steven Seagal during
an interview with Entertainment Weekly
Leguizamo certainly didn't mince words
when revealing where his the menu
character came from he told the outlet I
kind of based my performance on Steven
Seagal I had a bad run-in with him he's
kind of a horrible human what are you
blind we're closed okay
since Segal's position with the Russian
government is mostly honorary it doesn't
necessarily signify anything about the
actor's politics however it's harder to
say the same about Seagal's decision to
hold the 70th birthday party in Moscow
in April 2022 after all in attendance at
the bash were two pro-putin journalists
both of whom had already been sanctioned
by the European Union due to Russia's
controversial invasion of Ukraine seeing
as Putin's invasion of Ukraine occurred
only a few months prior in February of
2022 Seagal raised eyebrows when he told
his guests I love all of you and we
stand together through thick and through
thin Putin is not Segal's only
controversial friend in politics however
the actor has publicly voiced support
for former Philippine president Rodrigo
duterte a leader whose strict stance on
crime earned him the nickname The
Punisher Segal has also demonstrated his
support for Venezuelan president Nicolas
Maduro a leader whose divisive tactics
have led many news outlets to either
question his status as a Democratic
leader or outright pronounce him a
dictator
around the wrong people one of the great
gifts of being a famous actor is the
ability to diversify your income with
celebrity endorsements and Steven Seagal
hasn't missed the opportunity to do just
that in 2018 the actor lent an
endorsement to bitcoin 2 jet a
cryptocurrency aiming to rival Bitcoin
he also received a tidy sum for his
support however Segal failed to disclose
the payments he received which violated
U.S federal law and led to charges from
the Securities and Exchange Commission
according to the SEC Bitcoin 2 gen
promised to go 250 000 in cash and 750
000 worth of b2g tokens as payment first
promotions the actor ultimately received
around 157 thousand dollars but since he
never reported his earnings Segal got in
trouble on its website the SEC explained
the reasoning behind the charges writing
these investors were entitled to know
about payments to goal received Orr was
promised to endorse this investment so
they could decide whether he may be
biased Common Sense also supports the
sec's reasoning as celebrities obviously
advertise products they don't
necessarily support solely for the
paycheck to Segal's credit learning of
his offense he cooperated with the SEC
investigation ultimately paying around
three hundred and fourteen thousand
dollars in discouragement and penalties
in addition to John Leguizamo and the
cast of Saturday Night Live you can also
add Charlize Theron to the list of
celebrities who dislike Steven Seagal
during her June 22nd 2020 appearance on
the Howard Stern Show Theron made it
abundantly clear that she despises Segal
with a passion when Stern asks there and
how she prepares herself mentally for
her roles in action films the actress
said that she often watches YouTube
videos of martial artists in their
fights adding you always come across
that odd Seagal video of him fighting in
Japan but he really isn't he's
overweight and can barely fight look it
up it's ridiculous when Stern remarked
on how comfortable Theron seemed in
publicly mocking another well-known
industry professional the actress told
the host I have no problem talking about
Seagal because he's not very nice to
women though she didn't elaborate Theron
was likely alluding to the multiple
accusations of sexual assault and
misconduct leveled against the goal over
the years it's no secret that Steven
Seagal is known for his International
Adventures both on and off the screen as
a friend of Vladimir Putin Segal
continues to meet with the Russian
president fairly regularly but
apparently becoming a Russian citizen
wasn't enough for the American actor
according to CNN Putin honored Segal in
early 2023 with an order of friendship
as the news network noted Putin cited
the actor's great contribution to the
development of international cultural
and humanitarian cooperation as his
reasoning for the honor the award itself
is a relatively recent invention having
first been instituted by former
president Boris Yeltsin in 1994.
Seagal's award comes off the heels of
his 2022 visit to a destroyed Ukrainian
prison during the conflict between
Russia and Ukraine appearing on the
government-owned Network's yevsta Seagal
surveyed the damages with the intent of
educating those who haven't seen the
destruction firsthand it should be noted
however that the actor did all of this
from a kremlin-based perspective but
what more can be said about Seagal's
strange ties to Putin in the Russian
government the actor has made some very
interesting choices in recent years
including his Infamous birthday party in
Moscow he also consistently finds
himself honored by Putin in the Russian
government so one can only wonder what
position or award Steven Seagal will be
given next
if you or anyone you know has been a
victim of sexual assault help is
available visit the rape abuse and
incest National Network website or
contact Reigns National helpline at
1-800-656-hope 4673
[Music]